the global pandemic has hit  roma communities harshly and we must do  everything possible to address the  current crisis affecting roma  communities  and individuals and the work for  long-lasting  and progressive changes i have put  forward  concrete measures and tools to combat  anti-gypsyism  as a particular form of racism against  roma people and to advance roma  inclusion in member states to combat  discrimination  and anti-gypsiesism advance social  inclusion  promote participation and active  citizenship  and ensure effective equal access to  quality mainstream  education employment health  and housing  [Music]  you